よろしくお願いします
心所のもう一つの特色なんですけど
それはこのテキストのこの五十八ページの十七番目のこの決定不決定相応の心所と書いてるところですが
その決定不決定っていうのはまあ文字通りの訳なんですけど
別に決定という意味ではなくて
このある心所 心所がいつでも一緒に離れることはできないんですね
ある心所はお互いにあまり相性が良くないんですね
互いに ですからこの一緒には生まれません
まあそういうことなんですね
ですから この例えば一つの心所が生まれたら
確実にその心所と一緒に生まれる仲間がいるんですね
で それはもう決定という言葉で言ってるんですね
一つ生まれたら これとこれとこれはもう全然生まれませんよというふうにわかる
この決して一緒に生まれない
また心所のグループがあるんですね
まあそれそのところなんです
で そこでこの原文の通りに行くならばわかりやすいと思いますけど
イッサ・マッチェレ・クックッチェ・ヴィラティ・カルナーデヨ
その心所がいつでも別々に生まれるんだと
イッサというのは何でしたっけ？嫉妬ですね
マッチェレっていうのは物惜しみで
クックッチェっていうのは後悔
それはこの えーと 何でしたっけ
嫉妬することと物惜しむことと後悔することは一緒には生まれませんということなんですね
でもアビダンマでは これはこの痴根
瞋恨心ですか 怒りの心に生まれるんです
だから怒りなんですけど
だから怒りだから同じ仲間だから一緒に生まれるということはないんです
一つ生まれると もう他の心所が生まれないんですね
で 理由はこの前に説明しましたから
この例えばイッサ 嫉妬すると
嫉妬する場合は心の働きっていうのは自分には何かない
他人にはそれがある あるいは他人に何かがあって
自分にはそのものがない
その場合 生まれる怒りに嫉妬というんですね
なんで私にないんですかと
なんであの人にこれぐらいのこれぐらいのものあるんですかと
と ああ 嫌ですよと というふうな生まれる感情に嫉妬というんですね
それで物惜しみの場合はそちらの逆なんですね
自分にいろんなものがある
他人にそういうものはない
そうすると ない人々はそれはこう
それは一緒に使う可能性はあるんですね
例えば自分が自分の家で大変
何か豪華な 例えばテレビを買いましたと
友達がいて その人のアパートにテレビないんだと
これ随分高かったんだと
その人は自分の家に来たら当然それ見ちゃうんですね
そうすると友達にはない
自分には自分に何かがある
その場合は物惜しみが生まれる可能性あるんですね
迷惑ですよと と思ったりすると
来て偉そうにテレビをスイッチをいじったりとか
自分のもののように なんで見ているんですかとか
心の中で何か嫌な感情が生まれてくると
それは自分持っているものは他人共有するのは嫌という感じですから
それを物惜しみというんです
ですから 物惜しみの場合は
自分に何かがあって 他人にはそれがない
嫉妬の場合は自分にが何もなくて
他人に何かがあるという
ですから この対象が正反対
全く違うんです もっと違う言葉に入れ替えて言うと
自分が豊かな時は物惜しみが生まれる
自分が貧しい時は嫉妬が生まれるような理解した方がいいんです
ですから 自分の立場が正反対なんですね
ですから 同じ心で同じ心の中に物惜しみと嫉妬が生まれないんです
それは不可能ですと で
それから三番目の怒りの心所っていうのは後悔することなんですね
後悔する場合は 自分が何かしたことについて
あるいはしなかったことについて起こる怒りなんですね
あれできなかった 嫌だと思うと
それは後悔なんですね
あんなことをやってしまって
本当にもう良くないんだと
自分を責めたりすると
それも怒りなんですね
嫌な気持ちだから ですから
自分がしたこと あるいはしなかったことについて生まれる暗い感情は後悔というんですね
そうすると それと物惜しみと嫉妬っていうのは随分対象が違うんですね
一緒に全部できるわけじゃないんです
物惜しみをする場合は
心はもう自分のものを他人がこういう使うということは嫌で
怒りが起こるんであって
その時は自分過去でやったことやらなかったことについてはもう関係はないんですよ
そういうことで この怒りの心に生まれる
この一切合切くくっちゃという嫉妬と物惜しみと後悔という 3つが別々に生まれる
一緒には生まれません
ということは まあ一応理解した方がいいこと
次に 善心処の場合はヴィラティ
ヴィラティっていうのは何か何か何
この悪いことから自分を守ること
それをやめることなんですね
しないようにすること
することではなくて 何かしないようにする
心が何かしたがう このしたがるものはやらないで努力する
その努力するエネルギーがヴィラティというんですね
例えば酒飲みたいと心に感情が生まれる
その心に生まれるやれという感情が
私はやりませんと それはもう違うエネルギーで止まってもらう
そういうのはヴィラティというんですね
その場合は大体悪いことをしないことなんですね
心っていうのは普通は悪いことをしなさいというふうに
我々はいつでもこの何て言いますか
誘惑しているんですね
もう怠けなさいと 思い存分怒りなさいと
思い存分嫉妬しなさいと
思い存分物惜しみしなさいっていうのはすごいやりやすいんですよ
怒ることも 欲を作ることも
あるいはもうちんぷんかんぷんで妄想だらけで無知でいることも大変やりやすい
特別に努力しなくても
どんな生命にもそれぐらいのことはできるんですね
それで善心処っていうのはそんなにやりやすいものではなくて
いくらかの努力は必要になっちゃうんです
そこで この貪瞋痴の感情からやれやれと言っていることが
我々やらないで ちょっとちょっときついかもしれません
やらないで自分を守る
悪くしたら悪い結果が出てくるんだから
この場合は自分を守ると
やらないでいる そのやらないでいることも大変な力なんですね
普通の世間の言葉で何もしないでいるということは
ただ何の努力もないでしょうと思うかもしれません
でも何もしないでいることも
たまに大変なエネルギー必要とはするんです
それはもう何て言いますか
悪いことをしないでいることは大変な努力が必要なんです
例えば いいことをしないでいることには努力はいりません
悪いことをするためには努力いりません
それはもう自然的な感情だから
何の努力もなしに悪いことできる
何の努力もなしにいいことをしないで
ただ何もしないでいいことをしないでいることもできますけど
ですから この悪いことをしないということにも大変力が必要なんです
ですから それは明るい心処として善心処として言ってるんです
ヴィラティは 3つあるんですね
それは サンマーバーチャ
サンマカンマンとサンマアジーバ
この八正道に出てくる正語
正語と正命ですね で 正語
正しい言葉っていうのは
この まあ仏教においては言葉
あの悪い言葉は喋りやすいんですね
嘘は喋りやすいし 噂は喋りやすいし
喋りたくて喋りたくてしょうがないんですね
それから悪口ですか 人を傷つく言葉なんかはつい言いやすいんですよ
それから まあどうでもいい
何の意味もない無駄話っていうのは
また言いやすいものなんですよ
すごいメモを書いたりして
いろんな研究したりして
無駄話しゃべる必要ありますか？そうはないんで
なんであれ 僕もなしに無駄話はいくらでもできる
一生懸命研究してこのレポート書いたりして噂を言う人がいるんですかね
噂を言うんだからといって
何かメモを持ってきて
メモを見ながら人の噂を言うとか
そうはないんですよ その時はきちんと噂を喋るし
ですから そういう基本的な感情で努力はいらない
ですから この正しい言葉を使う
真実を語るためには大変な努力が必要になっちゃうし
噂言わないで黙ってるためにはかなり力が必要なんですよ
精神的に 人の噂を言いたくなる
でも言わない 言わないと
自分が自分を抑えて その抑えておくためにも力
エネルギーが必要なんですね
で 人に悪口言いたくなったところで言わないで
自分を抑えるためにも大変力が必要なんです
ですから 感情的に言葉使わないで言葉使わないと自分を抑えることは正語と呼ぶんですね
それと次に出てくるのは正業ですね
体の行動ですね で 体の行動の場合も悪いことはしやすいですよ
殺生することやら殺生することはしやすいし
面白いし だからみんな釣りとかね
大変趣味だとか スポーツだと
ゲームだと思ってやってる人はやってるでしょうに
で 昔はね もう半人とかいろいろゲームというものはありましたし
今もないわけないし 戦争することも結局はしやすいもんですよ
何のこともなく すぐそういうことに人を出して戦争させて人を殺したりするのは簡単なもんなんですね
で 人を殺すなと平和を守りましょうっていうのは
そんな簡単なものじゃないんです
大変難しいんです ですから
この体で行う行動っていうのは
殺生することと盗むことと
よこしまな行為なんですね
その三つから自分を守るためには努力が必要なんです
自然にできるものじゃないんです
ですから そこもヴィラティというし
その場合も心にすごくエネルギーが生まれるんですよ
そのエネルギーは悪いことをしないということから生まれるエネルギーだから
八正道にこれを正業と書いているんですね
サンマカンマンと で 三番目は正命ですね
仕事 だから生きるために何かしなくちゃいけない
それは普通に基本的な感情で生きることはどんな生命でも大変大事なことだと思ってるんですね
とにかく生きているという
生きていなくちゃいという感情があるんですね
ですから とにかくこの生きることは優先的な目的だから
それはもう先に行くのは普通なんですよ
で 例えば自分がどこかでどこに行こうとする
それで自分と一緒に行く人がすぐ何か病気になったとか
怪我しましたとかする
その場合は その怪我に手当すること
病気に何かすることは優先なんですね
その場合は 自分がどんな大事な
どんな楽しみな旅に出ようとしたっても
それはもう置いておいて
先に自分の目の前の優先なことをするんですね
その時 そんな理屈なんかは使わない
すぐ あ じゃあこれやりますと
旅は取り消しと 瞬間にそうなってしまうんですね
ですから この優先的なこと
行動ことっていうのは
優先だからいつでも優先になるんです
そこで生命の場合は 生きるということは一番優先なことなんですね
それより優先なことはないんです
とにかく生きてますということ
生きていなくちゃということは
生命 どんな生命もってる優先的な感情なんです
だから仏教ではそれを置いといてください
それは番目に番目にしてくださいと言ってるんですよ
別にそんなに必死にしなくたっても
どうせ生きてるんだから
死んだってまた輪廻転生するんだから
まあ全然もう努力しなくたってももうどうでもいいことなんですよ
ですから 必死になって努力しなくちゃいけないのは
この輪廻を止まってもらうことなんですね
ですから 仏教では優先なのはそういうことではなくて
人間の優先な行動というなら解脱することですよとはありますけど
でも別にそんなに必死になって頑張らなくたっても生命は生きているし
で 死ぬ時は誰でも死ぬし
それは避けられないし
死んでもまた生まれ変わっちゃうし
で終わりがない それなのにやっぱり生命欲があるんだから
無明があるんだから 生きること
死を避けること 優先だと思ってるんですね
ですから 生命を 自分の命を守るためであるならば
あるいは自分の命を危険に遭っているなと分かったら何でもするんですよ
何でもするんです だから命を守るためには
例えばずっと道徳を守ってきた人でも
今の場合 道徳を守ったら
まあ自分の生命が危険になりますよと思ったら
すぐその場でそれ破ってしまうんですよ
一生守ってきた道徳 道徳的な行為であろうとも
命に問題が出てきたら
すぐそれはもう後回しになる
その場で破る それが一般的な世の中の生命の生き方なんですね
ですから この正命の場合は
もう生きるためには何でもしますと
生きるためだったらしょうがないのではないかと
例えばお金は全くないんだと
もうで食べるものもないんだと
それだったらもうお金さえ入ればもう何でもするということに人がなってしまっちゃうんです
ご飯も食べなく 食べるものなくなっちゃったら
もう食べられるんだったら何でもするんだと
そういうふうにはなるんですね
そこで正命っていうのは
そういう生きるために何でもするんじゃなくて
生きるためには決して悪いことだけはしないんだと
そういう風に自分をコントロールするんですよ
生きるためには仕事はする
仕事はするんだけど 何でもするということはしないと
生きるためには悪いことだけはしませんと
いわゆる殺生はしませんし
泥棒はしませんし 嘘は言わないし
よこしまない行為もしませんしと
そんなこの言葉も守るし
体の行動も守るんです
守るんですね 悪いことをしない
それは正命なんです だからそれにもものすごく大変なエネルギーが必要なんです
正命の場合 そういうことで
そのその三つが仏教における道徳それぐらいなんですよ
道徳といえば 簡単に言えば仏教の道徳というのは正語正業正命という三つだけなんです
サッマーワーチャー サッマーとカンマンとサッマーアジーバ
その三つさえ守れば もう仏教的には完全な道徳を守る
倫理を守る人になるんです
で そこでこのここで言っているのは
この三つがいくら大事だと言っても
同じ心には一緒には生まれないんだと
だから一緒に生まれないと相性が良くないんですよ
いくらか どういうことかというと
この抑えるエネルギーは
その場その場で違うんですね
例えば何か喋りたくなった時は
その感情を抑えて真理だけで喋ると
その時は自分の命はどうしますか
ご飯はどうしますかとか
そこはもう考えていないし
仕事になった時は 自分の命を守ることになった時は
やっぱり命を守るためだと言ったって悪いことはしませんと
決める場合は また仕事は違うんですね
殺生しなくちゃいけないことになったところで
私は殺生しませんと それをやめると
ですから この その三つの善処が
そのそのものが抑える時生まれるんであって
一瞬瞬間で全てがかかってくるということはないんです
そういうことで そのヴィラティの三つ
サンマアーチャー サンマカンマンチャ
サンマアジーワという三つも別々には生まれる
一緒には生まれませんと
で とは言いますが 出世間の心では
いわゆる悟る瞬間では
ヴィラティは三つも一緒に生まれるんだそうです
このサンマアーチャー
サンマカンマンチャ サンマアジーワという三つ
一緒に生まれるんです
という風に言うんです
で なぜそう言いますかというと
この悟るためには八正道は実行しなくちゃ
八正道は方法であって
結果は悟ることであって解脱でありますから
方法はいくらか欠けていると正しい結果が得られないんですね
ですから 悟る場合は 心で八正道は完全に回らなくちゃいけないと
八正道は完全に満たした瞬間で悟りますよとは言ってるんですね
そうするとこの三つ一緒にならないといけないんですね
ですから その時の働きは違うんです
なぜならば 悟るために修行する人はもう初めからもう智慧は発達しているんですよ
その人は解脱したがっているんだから
生きていようとは思っていないんだから
どうなれば立派に生きていられるんですかとか
どうなれば豊かになるんですかとか
どうすれば天国に生まれ変われますかとかね
そういう考え方はもうまるっきりないんです
このすべての三界からどうやれば脱出できるかと
どうすれば輪廻転生を止めますかと
止められますかと そこら辺のレベルにいる人なんですよ
ヴィパッサナーの修行に入る人は
いわゆるヴィパッサナー始まる前にはかなり智慧を発達しておく必要がありますからね
ですから もう戒律のところから
仏教の知識から始まらなくちゃいけないんです
それを仏教の知識を得て
正しい真理を理解して
それからもう戒律を守ってみて
そこも大変いいことだと理解して
で それで瞑想してみて
心が統一することはどれほどいいことかと分かって
それで最終的にはすべてはやっぱり終了しなくちゃいけないという智慧が生まれたところで
もうヴィパッサナー始まるもんなんですけどね
これバナナを叩き売りみたいにヴィパッサナーやること分かりませんだけどね
もう何も知らない人々は
我々に強引に偉そうなこと言われても
教えてくれとかやらせているんだけど
だから言われるとやってあげなきゃ
もうそれにも怒られますから
でも結果もそれなりにそこそこでしょうし
ですから 正しい順番でやるならば
そんな 1週間も頑張らなくてもいいんですよ
だから私たちに文句言ったっても
あれ私たちのせいではないんです
まあいろいろ まあそれはそれで
ですから 悟るためにヴィパッサナーとかなんとかとかね
しようとする人がもうこの何かそのレベル超えてるんですね
悪いことしてはいけないとか
やっぱり嘘をつくのは良くないとかね
そういうレベルはもう嘘をつくとかじゃなくて
この輪廻にいたくないんですよ
生きるためにはやっぱり正しい仕事をしなくちゃ
生きるためじゃなくて生きていきたくないんですよ
その人が 生きても行きたくない人が嘘を言うとかね
人を騙すとか そんなありえない話なんです
ですから その人の心には
このヴィラティ この避けるというエネルギーが働いているんです
全部避けるんだと 身口意の行動はもう全部もう避けたいんだ
そういう働きだから そこでまとめて出世間のレベルでは正業正行と正命
3つ一緒に生まれるんだとは言うんです
それは出世間心だけなんです
普通の心では一緒には生まれません
それからカダーチマーナ
マーナという心所 マン
それはカダーチ カダーチっていう
んと ある時生じるんだと
ちょっと待ってください
まあ全部ある時に生じますけどね
マンの場合は 例えばマーナ
マンっていうのは自分と他人を比べることなんですね
測ることなんですね 自分と同じか上か下かどっちかと測る
それは自我中心的に自我がある人がいつでも他人と自分を比べることはやってるんです
だからといって まあずっとやってるわけでもないし
そういう他人と比べる時だけマーナという心所が生まれるんですね
それはこの貪瞋心の中に生まれるんですね
それはこのむさぼりの心
自我だから だから自我があるんだからといって
いつでも他人と測って比べてみるということはしない
そういう行動をしたがる瞬間で
マーナという心所が心の中に生まれてるんです
えーと ティーナミッダタターサハ
そこで昏沈睡眠は またある時生まれるものなんですけど
いわゆるいつでも昏沈睡眠があるわけじゃないという意味で
生まれるんだけど 昏沈睡眠はセットで一緒なんです
別々に生まれるものじゃないんです
ティーナミッダがいつでも一緒
ティーナが入っちゃうとミッダもあります
ミッダがあるとティーナもあります
いわゆる睡眠があるならば
必ずそこで昏沈があります
昏沈があったら一緒に睡眠もあります
という意味です ここで言わなかった心所がすべて四十一種類ありますけど
まあ確実にその心に生まれるんです
例えばむさぼりの心が生まれると
むさぼりの心所が必ずあります
怒りの心の場合は 怒りという心所が必ずあります
それから恐畏害心所もありますし
またこういうこういう心所が生まれるよと言ったならば
そういうものも生まれるし
善心所の場合も恐畏害心所と
それからこの十九の 何といいますかね
相分のサダーナのチェティセカというものがありまして
それは生まれるし でまあ決まってるものは生まれるんです
[咳]で 次にあのまああの
あのチャートを勉強するとすぐわかるものですから
あまりきめ細かくは説明しませんですけど
この十八番目サンガガーターということがありまして
心にどれぐらい心所が生まれるかと
出世間心には三十九種類の心所が生まれることと
それからパンチェティッサマハッガティ
マハッガティ心 大心というのはこの色界・無色界
瞑想して禅定を作った心に大心というんですね
第一禅定から まあそこで五つ禅定がありまして
無色界にはまた四つありますし
その色界・無色界で生まれる心所は全部まとめて十五プラス十二だから
あの二十七ですかな そういう心には心所は全部で三十五生まれるんですね
そこで欲界情心というのは
この普通の人間の清らかな心
別に瞑想しているわけじゃなくて
普通な清らかな心には三十八種類の心所が生まれる可能性はあります
不善心には心所が二十七個ですね
無因心っていうのは十八種類があります
そこで心所が十二種類が生まれるんです
で それはどういう心所かというのはリストを見てください
チャートを見てください
で そこで今日理解してほしいのは
たくさん心所が生まれるのは出世間心なんですよ
いわゆるヴィパッサナー瞑想の世界で悟る心には心所がたくさん生まれるんです
と三十五も生まれますから
三十六 で 三十六でいたっても一つ二つ減ったり大きくなったりはしますけど
だから三十六種類の全部心所がまとめてすごい強力な心なんです
ものすごい強力な心でないと悟るということは解脱するということは不可能なんですね
だから心所が現れると
その分心は強いんです
例えば我々が知っているのは不善心だから
不善心の例を出してみると
人が怒ったと 怒りも心所の強さによって強いんですけど
ただ嫌ですよと怒ったよりは
嫉妬する時は心のエネルギーは強いんです
人と怒るよりは その人に嫉妬する時は
自分がもっとより強いエネルギーを持ってるんです
なぜかというと もう一個増えてるんです
嫉妬という心所が たった一個増えるだけでかなり心の働きが違うんです
そこで物惜しむ場合も同じなんですね
ただ怒っただけよりは
物惜しむそれに入っちゃったら
より強い心になってしまうんです
だから強さっていうのは
いい方向に強いか悪い方向に強いか
それはどうでもいいんだけど
そこで無因心っていうのは一番心所の数が少ないんですね
ですから そういう心は
人は努力してもしなくてもどうしても生まれる心なんですね
ですから ヨーロッパ心理学で言っているこの無意識という働きは
大体無因心の方なんです
無因心というのは十八あります
でもそれは全部無意識とはあまりヨーロッパで言えませんだけどね
まあ自然の流れでどうしても生まれる
そんなにたくさん心所があるわけじゃないんです
ですから 力どうしても弱いんです
例えば何か見る時は あの
何て言いますか 視覚が生まれるんですね
この視覚心ですか このチャックリニャーナというんですけど
眼識 で 眼識っていうのは見たということだけなんですね
だから何の力もないんです
目を開けているんだから見える
耳があるんだから聞こえる
体があるんだからいろんなものを触れるとわかっている
それはそんな力がないんですよ
心所が七つしか生まれませんから
その場合は すごい弱い
でも 見たものについて頭で解釈するとすごい力が生まれてくるんです
見たものは何でしょうかと頭で考えるんだから
その心は力強いんです
ですから 我々が行動するのはその心なんですよ
見たんだから行動することはないんです
見たものは理解したところで
解釈したところで行動するんですよ
だから何か見て驚きましたと
その驚いたっていうことは
それ解釈の結果なんですね
だから驚くという体のすごい変化が起こる
で それには心所がたくさん必要なんですね
そういうことで心所があるということは
心の強さがかなりあるということで
で それで出世間心ではもう三十五ぐらい心所が生まれるんだから
一番強い心なんですね
不善心所の場合はあまりたくさん心が
心所が生まれません 全部数えたっても二十七なんですね
でも決して二十七全部揃ってる
揃って生まれるわけじゃないんです
決してそれはない ですから
そのチャートの中にそれを書いているんですね
貪瞋痴にどれぐらい生まれるかと
痴根にどれぐらい生まれるかと
瞋根にどれぐらい生まれるかっていうことは
このチャートの中に入ってるんです
例えば このチャートの番目はこの十九の心所が生まれると書いてあって
番目のこれは二番目っていうのはこの貪瞋痴の番目の心なんですね
ソーマナサハガタンディッティカッタサンパユッタササンカーリキチッタンという心なんですけど
その心にはが一が生まれるんだと
でもいつでもが一生まれるわけじゃない
この一番右側に書いている昏沈睡眠ですか
それはある時だけ生まれるんだから
そこで昏沈睡眠ない場合はやっぱり十九になっちゃうし
だからといって慢があると
なんで慢入ってないんですか？嫌悪と慢がないんだからね
で 次な嫌悪と慢が生まれないし
それから怒りの心には次は一番九番
十番目に行きますからね
まあこっちこの数書いてあっても
いつでも必ずしも生まれ生まれるわけじゃない
ですから それを理解するために
このアニエタ 不決定の心所は何でしょうかと覚えておけば
わかりやすいんです ですから
不決定 不決定と決定していない
お互いに相性が良くない信者は覚えておく
そういう風に他の信者は大体は生まれます
そこで 信者にもやっぱり強弱がありますから
悪い信者にもかなり強弱の差があります
怒りについても わずかな怒りから巨大な強烈な怒りまであるんです
で 怒って相手を殺すこともできるし
ただ怒って もう嫌な気持ちだけで終わることもあるし
嫌ですよという感情で終わるとこもあるし
例えば急に冷たい風が吹いて体に体に触れたら
別に気持ちいいわけじゃないんですね
嫌というふうな感情が生まれちゃうし
それも怒りといえば怒りなんです
でも だからといって何のこともないんですね
その場合はもうものすごい冷たい風が体に触れたら嫌だと自分が判断する
それは怒り 怒りですけど
人になんかさんざんけなされた時も
嫌ですよと感情が生まれる
その時の怒りと ちょっと冷たい風が体に触れただけの怒りっていうのは
もう随分差があるんですよ
ですから それは信者の強弱なんですね
ですから 信者が強くなるということは
我々は考えなくちゃいけないんですね
で 悪い方の信者ができるだけ強く生まれないようにしなくちゃいけないし
それ戒律の中ではそれを抑えてくれるんですよ
戒律守っちゃうと戒律守ったんだから悟るわけじゃないんだけど
やっぱり悪いことをしないんだから
悪い心は生まれるんだけど
心象が弱い 怒るんだけど
人を殺すまではいかない
怒るんだけど 人をぶん殴るとこまでいかない
弱さ 弱い心象で止まっちゃうんです
で 善心象の場合は弱い心象っていうのは何も役に立たない
ものすごい やっぱりいいことをしなくちゃいけないんだとかね
嘘を言うのは悪い 悪いだとかね
そんなちょっと思うだけでは何の役にも立たない
もう善心象かもしれませんだけど
すごく弱いんです それは心象が強くなったら
もう私は絶対嘘言わないと
すごい覚悟を決めて堂々と行動するようになる
それで善心象がかなり強烈なもう一番最高なレベルに発達したところで解脱することは可能なんですね
だから瞑想をもって何をしますかというと
やはり心象が 心象を磨くことなんですね
サマーディ瞑想ででも
この精進と統一性という心象がとことん磨くんですよ
繰り返して繰り返して繰り返して
もうどんどんどんどん心象のエネルギーをパワーアップするんですね
そこで随分パワーアップになったところで
もうサマーディという現象が生まれてくる
それでさらにさらにパワーアップすると
この八段階目のこのサマーディ色界・無色界のサマーディが生まれてくるんですね
色界・無色界のサマーディの場合は
やはり一境性という心象ですか
その定かげたという心象が育てるんですよ
いわゆる統一すること
で 他の心象の助けをもらわないで統一すること
我々にはこの統一するためにはいろいろ工夫しなくちゃいけないんですね
例えば勉強するときは
やっぱり集中したいんだからといって部屋の中に入るとか
窓を閉めるとか テレビを消すとか
いろんな工夫する あるいはテレビをつけておくとか
あるいはもう本が面白くないんだから
もう読めないんだからといって
みんな集まってる場所に行くとか
いろんな工夫するんですよ
一緒に勉強するとか 友達一緒に
そういう工夫しなきゃ
なかなか統一できないし
集中できない で 心象の方が弱くなってくる
強くなってくると そういう工夫なくても集中することはできてきますね
サマーディ瞑想での基本的な働きはそういう働きなんですね
初めはいろいろ工夫しますよ
マントラ唱えるとか 太鼓を叩くとか
音楽をつけるとか 香を立てるとか
踊りを使うとか そういうふうなことをやってやって
ある瞬間で そういうものに頼ることなく
心は集中するようになっちゃうんです
それは宗教でこのいろんなサマーディという状態
そういう状態なんですね
例えばマントラ唱えて瞑想するんだからって
マントラは一つの手段であって
それはもうありがたいと思って
大変不可思議な神秘的な力があるものやとか
グルから内緒で教えてくれた自分だけのマントラだとか
なんとかとか 絶対人にはこれは言ってはいけないとかね
そういう そういういろいろありますよ
全部ごまかしですけどね
私にグルが直接マントラを教えてくれた
これは私個人のマントラだと言ったのは
同じことみんなに教えてるんですよ
で 互いに自分のマントラは人に言ってはいけないんだと
人に言ったら力が抜けちゃうんだと
それである人にマントラ一つしか世の中で存在しない場合は
それはたとえ自分の母親にでも言ってしまったところで
効力なくなっちゃうでしょ
だから言わないんですね
誰も知らない それでそのシステムは守りますけどね
そういういろいろこのアクセサリーをつけてあげて
とにかく集中することを可能にしてあげちゃうんですね
そこでマントラをもうありがたい
ありがたいと思って念じたり念じていて